good evening at welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight we have exclusive new
information tonight about one of the
most perplexing mysteries in Washington
because you may have heard Andrew McCabe
he's the Deputy Director of the FBI
announced today he's leaving his job and
the most obvious question is why is he
doing that was he pushed heard he
decided to leave himself well you may
know McCabe's name because he's been in
the news repeatedly over the past
several years in 2016 it emerged the
McCabe's wife had taken a large sum of
money collected by one of Hillary
Clinton's closest friends this is
significant because mccabe himself
helped lead the investigation into
Hillary Clinton's email server you know
the one the investigation in which
Clinton was exonerated before she was
even interviewed McCabe never recused
himself from that investigation so was
Andrew McCabe fired today and was that
firing the result of information
contained in the still famous but still
mysterious House Intelligence Committee
memo the one everybody is talking about
but nobody outside of Congress has
actually read we decided to spend the
day finding out all we could about that
memo we made a lot of calls we talked to
quite a few people who have read it
here's what we learned the memo which is
four pages long primarily describes
abuses of FISA that's the law that
allows the US government to spy on
American citizens for the purpose of
stopping foreign threats and only for
that purpose spying on Americans is
supposed to happen only in extraordinary
circumstances and of course never for
political reasons that would be a
disaster
that's why we have FISA in the first
place to prevent that from happening but
that law has been abused and the memo
describes how quote it's shocking says
someone we spoke to who has read it it
doesn't answer every question it's not
the final word on anything but there's
definitely enough there for criminal
charges Andrew McCabe is indeed
mentioned in the memo a number of our
sources confirm that to us is that the
reason he left his jobs day we couldn't
get a definitive answer on that
it seems the memo likely played some
part in his leaving but in the course of
our reporting we learned something else
from the source McCabe is the subject of
at least one internal DOJ investigation
maybe more
DOJ Inspector General Michael Horowitz
has been investigating politically
motivated behavior at the bureau during
the 2016 election one source told us
that McCabe's resignation is likely tied
to horowitz's work other outlets have
reported that FBI director Christopher
Rea proposed demoting McCabe over the
findings of the Inspector General among
the subjects of FISA warrants described
in the memo is Carter Paige who was
affiliated with the Trump campaign as a
foreign policy adviser of some sort the
Obama Justice Department argued before a
federal judge and memo describes this
that Paige was an active agent of a
hostile foreign government a spy for
Vladimir Putin more than a year later
that claim looks absurd ridiculous
actually because it is Paige has never
been indicted for spying for anybody no
evidence has surfaced at all to suggest
that that's even close to true by the
way if Paige is a Russian agent why
isn't he in handcuffs right now why is
he on MSNBC all the time
this is nuts yet on the basis of that
nutty claim the Obama Justice Department
was able to secretly surveil the Trump
campaign not a small thing the memo also
apparently shows that when the DOJ
wanted to extend spying on Carter Paige
they used information from the now
discredited steel dossier to make their
case if you can even imagine that was
the basis of their request to the
federal judge to keep a spying program
in place as one person freely through
memo puts it quote the FBI has been
steadily politicized for years now it's
being exposed for efforts to undermine
and D legitimize a political candidate
now we don't know if that's true we
haven't seen the memo or the documents
that support it neither has almost
anybody commenting on it but these are
serious allegations they are more
troubling than the underlying crime in
Watergate that's for sure you don't have
to be a trump voter to understand
whether political use of intelligence
and law enforcement agencies can destroy
a country almost faster than anything
else can yet Democrats don't care how do
we know they don't care
we checked as of tonight according to
house Intel committee staff about a
hundred and ninety Republicans in the
House outside the Intel committee have
read that
memo meanwhile outside the committee
only about a dozen Democratic members
have read it
what's interesting amazing if you think
about it is that though only a few
Democrats have bothered to read the memo
they are all to a person adamantly
against releasing it but it doesn't
matter what they want it looks like the
rest of us will be able to make our own
judgments about what's in that memo very
soon the House Intelligence Committee
voted tonight to declassify it according
to our sources the entire memo will
likely be read into the congressional
record early next week
dan bajeena was a former Secret Service
agent and the NYPD officer and he joins
us tonight dance great to see you good
to be here Tucker so I mean my view from
day one has been it's not about Trump
it's not about Obama it's about the
political use of our Intel and
law-enforcement agencies and what we
learned today about the memos suggests
that that has happened
they've been politicized Tucker where
are the Democrats on this I thought this
was the party of civil liberties exactly
this is you do not have to be a trump
supporter to understand that the
constitutional republic as we know it
cannot continue to exist if the Fourth
Amendment is subject to the are the D in
front of your name make no mistake
because the Liberals are hiding now and
they're all scurrying like roaches when
the lights come on they know what
happened here to spy on someone in the
United States is legal if you can
produce probable cause using legal means
of a crime or that someone is acting on
behalf of a foreign agent in violation
of some United States crime none of that
has been produced to this day not a
single Democrat Republican or anyone
else has produced a scintilla of
evidence that anyone on the Trump team
and we're not talking about process
crimes later colluded with the Russians
to justify an investigation to spy into
what at the time was a candidate for
president United States of the opposing
party this is devastating
where are the so-called civil liberties
what could possibly be the rationale for
not reading the memo under current house
rules any member of the house can go in
you have to go to a secure location but
if you're an elected member the house
you can read it only a dozen Democrats
out of more than a hundred outside the
committee have done that what how could
they explain that here's what's going on
here the way sensitive classified
sensitive comp rat excuse me compartment
the lies information works the systems
aren't interconnected Tucker so when I
would say in a skiff vet when I worked
in the Secret Service there's
information on certain systems that's
not connected to the cloud or the
internet it is in Tucker's place right
for someone to read that you have to go
to Tucker's place it is not a
coincidence that Devin Nunez who has an
entire scope of what happened went back
in March through the White House
facility to read very specific Intel
that I think is very likely will be in
this memo what am I saying by this that
that information was likely briefed to
Barack Obama what does that mean that
means that this information was being
used by Hillary and all this other stuff
that was in the dossier and all of this
spying was probably being inserted into
daily briefs by Barack Obama
why else would Nunez have to go to the
White House to read it that's that's a
great point and of course it was the
Obama administration that pushed for the
surveillance powers over the Trump
campaign very quickly is it plausible
that Trump the Obama administration
officials really believed that poor
Carter page I'm sure you've seen him in
his television appearances was a Russian
agent was working for bladder Putin do
you think they really believe that when
they asked for the right to spy on him
I believe when you think Donald Trump is
Satan you can convince yourself of
absolutely it's probably exactly right
nicely put and true Dan thank you thank
you sir